cool we'll talk about a periodic mono
it's yes saturated models yes thank you
pro a periodic mono it via saturated
models last talk of the day I'm doing
this this joint work with Ben Steinberg
in New York where I'm currently a merry
kiri fellow and I'm really happy to
present this work here it's about logic
and computation at least maybe you can
tell me where the symmetry is so in the
theory of regular languages of finite
words profile night MA noise you've
probably heard are useful canonical
objects and as I'm very grateful Daniela
already explained earlier today such
Mahanoy tarstone dual spaces of certain
boolean algebra so any profile net
monoid is in particular stone space and
these boolean algebra is you may think
of them as boolean algebra of languages
but you may also think of them as
boolean algebra is coming from logic
certain logical theories I will explain
this a little bit better in the rest of
this talk but the question now is well
if these profile night MA nodes are just
space is coming from logic then we
should be able to use logic to analyze
those profile night modes and that's
what we're starting to do here in this
talk will just focus on first order
logic I don't think that's a neccessity
necessary restriction but that's where
we're most comfortable with doing model
theory ok so that's why we're doing
first order logic for now so then
there's this classical theorem that a
language I'm always talking here about
languages of finite words a language of
finite words is first order definable if
and only if it's syntactic monoid is
finite and a periodic in other words
it's recognizable by a finite a periodic
Malloy d I'll denote that class just buy
a boat phase a and then actually if you
think a little bit about this what this
theorem says is that if you assign to
every first-order sentence
the language that it defines that is
simply an isomorphism between the
lindenbaum algebra the algebra of
sentences up two equivalents and the
algebra of language is recognizable by
in a periodic moment okay so star free
languages a periodic recognizable
languages that boolean algebra is just a
lindenbaum algebra of some first order
theory namely those sentences which are
true in all finite eight words okay up
to that theory you look at all the
sentences that's the same boolean
algebra so if you now take stone duel
spaces what is known from the theory of
stone duality is that this notation
denotes the free pro a periodic monoid
that is the stone duel space of the
recognizable languages the a periodic
recognizable ones but since that boolean
algebra is also the Lindenbaum algebra
of this theory the duo spaces are the
same okay so if you read this equation
it tells you that there's a way to view
the free pro a periodic mono in a
structure that's been studied a lot in
mono in theory to view it as the dual
space of a certain logical algebra ok
and that's kind of the starting point
here so we can analyze the free pro a
periodic malloy d as a dual space of a
lindenbaum algebra so let's look a
little bit about what this dual space of
a lindenbaum algebra is this is a well
known thing and logic if you have any
first order theory whatsoever then the
points of the dual space of the liniment
algebra those are just the complete
theories that extend your theory ok just
in the sense of usual logic they're also
the ultra filters of the boolean algebra
right that's the same thing another way
to say it is if you think more
semantically if you don't want sets of
sentences but you want actual models you
could say well a complete theory it's
consistent so it always has a model it
has a lot of different models so I can
regard one complete theory
as a whole elementary equivalence class
of models with that feeling right the
same thing so the points of this space
our elementary equivalence classes of
models of tea and then what is the storm
topology it's simply the logical
topology so for any first-order sentence
I can look at what I call Phi hat which
is the set of those classes of models
where that sentence is true ok that's a
basis for the clopin sets for my
topology so in particular now applying
this principle to the theory of finite
words over a finite alphabet a that's
what this space here looks like so the
free pro a periodic minoan over a finite
set a can be viewed as the space of
elementary equivalence classes of pseudo
finite words where by pseudo finite word
I mean a model of this theory TFM that's
some stone duality yoga essentially but
now how to use this ok so this is just a
space for now I just have a space
underlying this mono it and the space
underlying that mono it its points are
just elementary equivalence classes of
models but that means i should be able
to multiply such models right because it
comes from a mono it and i should be
able to do anything i can do in the free
paper yelling mono it I can ask well
what am I actually doing with those
models if I can describe an operation on
those models it should be invariant
under elementary equivalence hopefully
right so that it actually becomes a
well-defined operation here so it kind
of gives you a different way of viewing
the free pro a periodic mahanoy and in
the last part of my talk I will tell you
a bit about how to use that to actually
get some insights about the free poetic
monoid so let me now zoom in a little
bit more on what these models are ok so
i will call in this for the purposes of
this talk i would call an a word a
structure in this first order signature
la which just consists of the binary
relation which will be the order and
then predicates for every letter okay as
you're used to when you're doing logic
over words so then an a word just means
a discrete linear order with endpoints
and the predicates form a partition a
suit of finite a word is a model of the
theory of finite words so this notation
suggests that that's a special kind of a
word right and it's actually true
because this theory itself is not
finitely eczema thaisa belitz not enough
to just say oh I have a discrete linear
order where the predicate is from a
partition there's a lot more that's true
about models of the theory TF in a word
is here's a way to describe it a word is
pseudo finite if and only if every first
order formula that is true somewhere in
the word okay I have a first-order
formula with the parameter if it's true
somewhere then it's true for a first
time that's a property that an a word
could have or not have and if it has it
if and only if its pseudo finite so it's
a model of the theory of finite words so
so the typical example is a word like
this start with the order of the
naturals labeled by a and then the
reverse of the order of the natural
labeled by be okay there's no first
occurrence of a peek here so it's not
pseudo finite it isn't legal a word but
it's not a suit of finite a word and now
actually for most of this talk I don't
need to know that the word is pseudo
finite I can do a lot of what I'm going
to do so the suit of finite words form
the free pro a periodic mahanoy the a
words up to elementary equivalence form
another Pro a periodic Malloy it's much
bigger than the free pro a periodic
Malloy d but I can still do a lot of the
things I can do with the free pro a
periodic my night with that bigger
moment so in particular if you take any
two a words you can concatenate them
right you just put them next to each
other very concretely as models and this
operation as is well known respects
elementary equivalence if you do this to
two pairs of elementary queer
words you can catenate them the result
is still elementary equivalent and that
is how this space of models is now a
monoid as well and you have to check
that the operation is continuous
actually another way to see it if you
don't like topology is to go to the dual
space and go to the Lindenbaum algebra
there is a corresponding operation to
this ma noi bolta plication on the
boolean algebra as usual with stone
duality everything you have on one side
on the space side it translates to
something on the boolean algebra side
here the corresponding thing is what's
called a residual operation and this is
a maybe a nice exercise if you have to
first order sentences then there always
is a sentence that defines the following
language the language of those finite
words such that if you take another word
that satisfies I and you multiply it on
the right you get a word that satisfies
Phi ok that is another new language then
defining and it's still first order
definable if the other two are actually
you can say something much more general
if you instead of concatenating words
you can just substitute words into words
right you notice about finite words but
the same goes for pseudo finite words so
if you think of a pseudo finite word
it's a model or even just for any a word
as I've define it it's a model with a
discreet order if I label it by letters
and now I choose for each letter I
choose another word then I can plug it
in yeah you have to define it properly
you take the lexicographic order etc but
I think the idea of what the
substitution should be is clear and then
this so any assignment of words of
letter from the letters of these
alphabet be two classes of words in the
alphabet a actually gives me a
well-defined substitution for any word
over B to a new word over a ok so this
is again you have to prove that it
respects elementary
etc so as I mentioned there's actually a
larger pro a periodic ma night but all
of this takes place so if you just look
at the theory of a words and you play
the same game you look at the classes of
models of this theory that's called that
Pro a periodic mono that we get lambda
of a lambda to indicate linear orders
then the concatenation and substitution
operations are well defined on a words
this lambda of a becomes a pro a
periodic mono it and it contains the
free pro a periodic montoya which were
just the pseudo finite a words as a
closed submited and moreover the
compliment is an ideal so by multiplying
non pseudo finite things you always
remain non pseudo finite ok so now I
told you I want to use some techniques
from classical model theory to analyze
the pro a periodic mono it so far I've
just shown you that the free pro a
periodic mono it can be viewed as a
mullet of models but now we're going to
use in particular saturated models to
have a really nice easy combinatorial
way to look at those models and look at
the corresponding elements of the pro a
periodic mono it so for that I recall a
little bit of model theory now I won't
recall the general definitions I will
just tell you what they mean in the case
of finite words ok so it's a very
reduced view of classical model theory
so a type that would be called a
complete one type in model theory is
just a triple where I have to a words
and a letter in the middle and the type
space is this product here why is that a
type because essentially if I have an a
word and I have a position I can look at
the theory of what happens to the left
of that position the theory of what
happens to the right of that position
and what letter do I have that
completely describes the whole first
order type of that word with a marked
position right
and now that's the type realized in a
word now we call a type consistent if
it's realized in some elementary
equivalent word okay so it may not be
realized in the word in fact a word is
what corresponds to weekly saturated if
it actually realizes all the types that
are consistent with it will have an
example in the next slide because now a
word is omega saturated if this holds
Herod it thoroughly so that's again
Omega saturated there's a model
theoretic definition of it but here it
amounts to saying that as soon as you
choose an interval so you choose two
positions and you look in between those
positions that should be weekly
saturated that is equivalent to being
Omega saturated which would a model
theory mean you mark a bunch of
positions but then you can look in each
interval ok so now from model theory any
elementary equivalence classes actually
contains an Omega saturated model so we
can actually assume that the points of
this Pro a periodic Malloy are just in
each class I choose an Omega saturated
one if i want to write so in the one
letter alphabet what does what do all
the saturation notions mean well first
of all I can look at the word which is
just Omega and Omega reversed that's not
even weekly saturated because there is
an elementary equivalent one where I put
the integers in the middle and that one
I cannot realize by taking a type here
right I cannot because there's no middle
in this one so I cannot I cannot find a
type here that's that has the type that
I would get it here in the elementary
equivalent model I choose a point in the
middle I see something infinite on the
left and infinite on the right in this
model so this model actually is weakly
saturated any type that I can realize in
the class is already realized here but
not every interval is weakly saturated
to get that every interval so its weekly
because I might take if I if I'm unlucky
and I pick a position here
then the interval on the right is just a
interval in the ride as a finite word I
guess I have to take a word here a point
here right and then what i get if i look
to the left of that point i get this one
which i already told you isn't weekly
saturated so now finally if you iterate
adding the integers in the middle you
get densely many copies of the integers
this ordinal here so this means the
dense linear order countable and this
means the integers ordinal product and I
take a beginning and an end then I have
an Omega saturated word okay so this is
just for the one letter alphabet in more
letter alphabets it becomes more
complicated what these saturated models
look like okay but I at least for model
fear we know that I always have them in
every class and now kind of an important
fact that makes the machine work is that
if you choose Omega saturated words and
you substitute them into Omega saturated
words the result is still omega
saturated in particular if you
concatenate I didn't mention this but
concatenation is a very simple
substitution into the word 01 or a B
yeah where you put something in the
first place put something in the second
place and power by this special Omega
saturated linear order row that's also a
kind of substitution because if i take
that order with all the time the same
letter and now in that letter i put no
matter what word I want then I get the
power of that word right I get that word
repeated row times so all of these
things if I start from Omega saturated
words i obtain omega saturated words so
that's the model theory machinery that
we're using here and proving this
theorem you can nicely do using it the
stone topology on the space of models
and the fact that substitutions are
continuous and it's actually kind of a
proof once you easy proof once you
realize what all these things mean
topologically so now from this fact that
I have as many that I have saturated
models in every class I can recover some
facts that were known about the free pro
a periodic mono I'd in fact now I can
prove them for that larger pro a
periodic Mahanoy lambda a for example
amyloid is called Peck we divisible if
that quazy equation there holds
it may be at this time of day that it's
not that easy to par so it's easier to
just draw a picture if I have that if i
multiply a word you with the word V and
I multiply word u prime with a word V
Prime and the result is the same then it
must be the case that there is actually
a word which will be this word X here so
sorry here was you here was V Prime
here's a word X so that if I do u prime
if I do u times X i obtain u prime and
if I do x times V Prime I do view ok
it's kind of an obvious property if you
are thinking of finite words right and
now this ma noi dove all the a words up
to a mentor equivalence is also equity
visible and the proof is well take their
product and now pick for that product a
saturated model you know that it exists
from model theory and then in that
saturated model you know that all the
types you want that might happen in
elementary equivalent models are
actually realized in that word so now
you draw that picture okay so you draw
that picture about the word w pick a
model which is saturated and you know
that both this gluing position here and
this gluing position here I realized and
now I just take the class of this word
okay the way it is of course these kind
of proof so this is in fact known to be
true for any profile I think even for
any compact monoid but the way it would
usually be proved is by taking sequences
taking their limits and showing that
everything works here i have a kind of
the proof you think of in finite words
you can basically copy it and justify it
by using omega saturated models so now
as a further more advanced application I
won't show you all the details of this I
think but if I have a substitution okay
from this big model of all the b-word a
big Mahanoy dove all the B words to the
night of all da words suppose I choose
for every letter a class you of B and
suppose that I now at what I'm going to
do is I'm going to analyze the factors
of a substitution so I take a word V i
substitute into V and I take a factor W
so W if i multiply it in the right way
on the on the left and on the right then
I get the result of substituting into V
then what i know is that i can choose
omega saturated words in each of these
classes and the fear in tells me that if
i choose for my indexing word v and for
the words that i'm substituting it for
all of those i choose omega saturated
words the resulting word of substituting
all this stuff is still omega saturated
in particular what that means is that if
i take any factorization by some word w
it's actually going to be realized in
the result of substituting so
classifying factorizations which if you
were just thinking of this as some
compact mono it might have been hard now
becomes just a combinatorial problem of
classifying what the intervals in this
very concrete model v
Capital V with all the models you be
substituted are so just to show again in
a picture how that would look you have
an indexing model V which you know is
saturated and for each point here you
substitute another so if this was a
letter B you substitute a word you be
and you do that for every letter get
some big substituted model and now you
have some factorization it might cut
through some substitutions but what you
can now say is that whenever you've
taken interval here it will be a suffix
of one of the words you're substituting
then it will be some interval here where
I just substitute all the words I want
and then I get another prefix of the
last word that I wasn't completely
taking that makes sense so that way I
can completely understand what all the
factorizations of a substitution are and
using that kind of method you can now
prove for example a result biomedical
stands attuned that in the free pro a
periodic Malloy if you take a prefix
suffix or a factor of an element that is
given by an Omega term it's still given
by an Omega term where Omega terms if
you start from letters you can always
generate with concatenation and doing
idempotent power that's the what the
Omega stands for here and the words that
you get are a special sup ma annoyed of
the free pro a periodic malloy d but if
you take pre prefix of such a thing it
may cut somewhere in the middle and you
may not know that you can still describe
it with an Omega term but the theorem
tells you it's true and using this
factorization it's actually not that
hard to show so I think I'll skip the
proof but in detail but the idea is
simply to analyze what the factor
can look like in the concrete model so
you use here in particular in the case
of the Omega power you use the fact that
the saturated model for Omega is this
dense order with a beginning and an end
and you just cut it somewhere and you
see that all you can get is either a
natural an actual natural number or
again an infinite infinitely many copies
okay then there are here some
advertisement we have a preprint on
archive for other things you can do with
these techniques so you can use it to
analyze the structure of both of these
modes you can prove things that were
used by ben stein work in collaboration
with Hank oh and roads to analyze stable
pairs so they prove that I'm not sure if
all these results are theirs but they
use them in any case in that paper so
unambiguous of the l and r orders the
fact that the l and our orders are total
and stabilizers this is all in our paper
using these new methods also to decide
whether to Omega terms are equal there
was a few years ago approve an algorithm
by Hubert and cough leitner who proved
that if you interpret Omega terms in the
right way then they are element airily
equivalent if and only if they are
isomorphic and actually the way that
they interpreted them they didn't say
that but we realize that they
interpreted them as countably saturated
models always well from model theory
countably saturated models are
equivalent if and only if they are
isomorphic so there one crucial part of
the result becomes clear from model
theory in this way then we looked at
well Kwazii orders of factors having a
well Kwazii order effectors is stable
under substitution if you analyze the
fed of the factors in this way having a
regular language of finite factors is
another property that's stable under
substitution and so in particular Omega
terms by induction Omega terms have both
of these properties and that's all I
wanted to show you
[Applause]
sir question comment and I guess you
were thinking about deciding heavens
exciting Emma so furious have started
and so if you go to a slightly higher
level and you take that MSO profile
night moment to the right man when I
appropriately formalized annasophia
becomes undecidable so which way do you
think this is going to go here what was
your conjecture wait but for finite I'm
just doing finite words for now right so
then MSO is just your lawn local take
issue with the motor scooter spite
contains so you could run them is all of
that hmm yes thundered semantics yeah
and then you could consider the problem
given an MSO formula is it true in a
model of your form and where you mean
the more general models or the or the
pseudo finite ones like I in this video
finite ones i have no conjectured to
make about that but it's almost like it
no no no okay yeah
well we do have a reception waiting for
us so that's the tank Sammy again
[Applause]